aquí tenemos la gráfica de la función f
que asumimos que es una función de t
pues aquí tenemos el eje horizontal t
así es que es la gráfica de f
efe minúscula dt y ahora definamos otra
función la función f mayúscula pero no
va a ser una función de t va a ser una
función de x y la vamos a definir como f
mayúscula de x es igual a la integral
definida la integral definida desde que
te vale menos 5 hasta que te vale x
de hecho déjame ponerlas x con el mismo
color
efe mayúscula de x la integral desde t
igual a menos 5 hasta que igual a x de f
de t de t y quizá aquí para evitar
confusión hubiera usado mejor no sé qué
mayúscula para no tener que mezclar efe
mayúscula efe minúscula pero voy a
tratar de acordarme de esto y precisar
efe minúscula dt f mayúscula de x y así
evitar confusión pero así es cómo
definimos
efe mayúscula de x como la integral
desde que te iguala menos 5 hasta que te
iguala x de ft dt y lo que quiero que
hagamos en este vídeo es encontrar para
qué valores de x la función f mayúscula
se hace cero para que valores de x
efe mayúscula de x es igual a cero vamos
a escribir eso para que valores
de x f mayúscula de x es igual a 0
o para ser más precisos para que valores
de x se cumple la ecuación f mayúscula
de x es igual a 0 te invito a que le
pongas pausa al vídeo e intentes hacerlo
por tu cuenta antes de que lo hagamos
juntos supongo que ya lo intentaste así
es que ahora veamos de qué se trata esta
función f mayúscula de x para ver esto
recordemos que la integral definida nos
da el área en este caso va a ser el área
entre t igual a menos 5 y te iguala x
que se encuentra por debajo de la
gráfica de f dt y por arriba del eje t
pero si la gráfica de la función se
encuentra por debajo del gt entonces el
área va a tener signo negativo así
tenemos entonces que desde que te iguala
menos 5 de igual a menos 5 es este
límite se esta recta desde que te igual
a menos 5 hasta que te iguala x
supongamos que x
es igual a menos 2 que este es el valor
de x este sería el otro límite entonces
f mayúscula de x nos va a dar el valor
de esta área así es que en particular en
este ejemplo f mayúscula de menos 2
tendría un valor negativo pues la
gráfica de la función se encuentra por
debajo del eje de ahora para que valores
de x sea sexto cero bien hay uno que es
evidente que tal si hacemos x igual a
menos 5 haciendo x igual a menos 5 no
habría ancho en la región por lo cual el
área sería 0 así es que f de menos 5
efe de menos 5 de hecho f mayúscula de
menos 5 tengo que ser preciso aquí
efe mayúscula de menos 5 es igual a la
integral de menos 5
al menos 5
de ft
dt y aquí dado que los límites de
integración son iguales no hay ancho en
la región sobre la cual vamos a integrar
por lo cual como mencionamos esta
integral es igual a cero podemos
entonces empezar nuestra lista con x
igual a menos 5 como uno de los valores
que hace f mayúscula de x igual a cero
veamos si podemos encontrar más valores
si nosotros vamos desde x igual a menos
5 déjame borrar esto de aquí
bien si empezamos en x igual a menos 5 y
terminamos en x igual a menos 3 entonces
vamos a tener esta área como el
resultado de la integral el área de esta
región que corresponde a un triángulo
cuya base es 2 vamos a ponerlo aquí la
base de este triángulo es 2 y la altura
que es 4 con lo cual el área de este
triángulo es 2 por 48 entre 2 es igual a
4 pero como la región se encuentra por
arriba de la gráfica de la función y
debajo el eje te vamos a tomar este
valor como menos 4 ahora empezamos en x
igual a menos cinco donde f mayúscula de
x es igual a cero nos movimos hacia la
derecha y obtuvimos un valor negativo y
a medida que nos movemos más hacia la
derecha obtenemos valores que son cada
vez más negativos he tomado el valor de
la función en este punto pues aquí hay
un cambio de forma en la gráfica de la
función es decir vamos
tener el área de esta región que va a ir
haciendo que f mayúscula de que sea cada
vez más negativa a medida que aumenta el
valor de x ahora si observamos esta
región parece corresponder a un cuarto
de círculo un cuarto de círculo de radio
4 y aquí tenemos otro cuarto de círculo
de radio 4 cuando llegamos a x igual a 5
aunque aquí el área la vamos a tomar
como positiva pues la gráfica de la
función está arriba del eje y que ha
sucedido entonces cuando hemos llegado
hasta acá iniciamos en x igual a menos 5
donde ya vimos que el valor de f
mayúscula de menos 5 es igual a cero
vimos que a medida que aumentaba x el
área se hacía cada vez más y más
negativa pero aquí empieza a hacerse
menos negativa pues empezamos a agregar
valores positivos así por ejemplo aquí
en x igual a 2
cuando x es igual a 2 tendremos esta
parte positiva que va a contrarrestar un
poco lo negativo pero aún así f
mayúscula va a seguir siendo negativa
pero a medida que avanza la x por acá
efe mayúscula va a ser menos negativa de
tal manera que cuando llegamos a x igual
a 5
de este cuarto de círculo que tiene un
valor positivo va a compensar el valor
del área de este cuarto de círculo que
es negativa no necesitamos calcularlo
puedo hacerlo con pi por radio al
cuadrado sobre 4 pero no es necesario
esto aquí vemos gráficamente que se
compensan ahora lo que necesitamos es
aumentar área positiva para cancelar
este menos 4 y como hacemos esto bueno
aquí tenemos que esta altura mide 4 esta
altura mide 4 así es que si ahora
aumentamos el área en un rectángulo que
tenga altura 4 y base 1 obtendremos un
área de 4 esta área el área de este
rectángulo es 4 y ya compensamos este
menos 4 que tenemos aquí así es que el
valor de f mayúscula de 6 es igual a 0
vamos a poner eso por acá vamos a
escribir eso acá abajo
efe mayúscula de 6
es igual a la integral la integral
definida desde que x es igual a menos 5
hasta que x es igual a 6 de efe
minúscula de t
dt y esto lo podemos separar como ya
hicimos esto lo único que quiero
cerciorarme de que lo hemos comprendido
bien esto es igual a ni lo va a ser en
un solo color ahora esto es igual a no
mejor lo hacen los colores que están
aquí esto es igual a la integral de
menos 5
- 3
de ft dt
más la integral
de menos tres a uno de ft dt más
la integral de 1 a 5 de ft
dt que es esta región que tenemos aquí y
finalmente
más más la integral de 5 a 6
de ft
dt así es que está integral de aquí
describe esta área de aquí con signo
negativo esta de aquí estaré aquí con
signo positivo que son iguales así es
que estas se cancelan da al cero esta
área de aquí es menos 4 más bien el
valor de esta integral es menos 4 esto
vale menos 4 y el valor de esta integral
ya lo calculamos que es igual a 4 menos
cuatro y cuatro se hacen cero así es que
esta integral vale cero que era lo que
estábamos buscando de nueva cuenta como
hice esto cuando x igual a menos 5 no
hay área la integral vale 0 ya partir de
ahí fue aumentando para valores de x
cada vez más grandes lo podría haber
hecho hacia el otro lado
sin embargo obtendría valores positivos
cada vez más grandes para el área con lo
cual la integral nunca se haría 0 pero
para x mayor a menos 5 a medida que
vamos aumentando el valor de x el valor
de f mayúscula es cada vez más más
negativa hasta que llegamos al valor de
x igual a 1 donde comienzan a aparecer
ya valores positivos que empiezan a
compensar todos los valores negativos
hasta que llegamos a x 6 donde el valor
de fe mayúscula nuevamente llega a ser
cero